中大膽週報公開版277集
大盤從破4萬點一路反攻
一路公公公到4萬6千點的附近
但是在週五出現了一些些的壓力
我們也有看到這幾天有一些好的現象
例如說外資有回來買
所以對於最新的一個禮拜佈局
到底種種怎麼看呢
好的 這一波的股票市場上的指數
有來到我先減所預估的4萬5千點左右
那我4萬5千點
我都會建議投資本
就把持股降低到5成左右
那很多人就會覺得說
總總這一波好像你看不太準
坦白講 我看的準或怎麼不準
不是那麼重要的是
最重要的是
我要讓你賣在可以賣的位置去
相對好的位置
舉個例子
我們上次建議大家
在前一波的時候
建議大家4萬6千500點以上你就賣
那後來我就最高4萬8
那沒有人可以賣到最高像4萬8這個位置
通常的這一波呢
也曾經跌破4萬點
那我的建議通常就在4萬1左右
你就開始更要積極去買
所以呢
我永遠就是抓那個比較
你可以適當的賣出
也可以適當的買進
那4萬5000點
淘寶現在正在這個整數關卡的
這部分是我整理的部分
雖然已經過
但是呢
我之前有講過
百分之三的測試理論
所以進行4萬5000過
但是要觀察一段時間
到底能不能順利的站穩才最重要
這一次整個大盤的走勢能夠超乎我的預期
或是市場很多人的預期
最主要就是雙I效應
就是包括CPI
還有包括MACI
坦白講這兩個部分
我個人覺得是CPI的部分倒還好
是因為我們之前應該
大家應該預期應該會不會升息
那麼快
MACI是之前大家認為說
應該會降
比較精釀
三聲
而且它這是納入的
個股
還有包括中小型個股
算是蠻多的
我覺得這個部分是比較
跌破市場上的眼鏡
但原則上如果你4萬5賣
跟你後面那到4萬6
其實那1000點左右
你是不是會抱得相對的
不是那麼安心
所以我個人認為說
4萬5賣掉沒關係
反正我們之前跟各位提到過
你手中還要五成
你不見得一定要把手中的部位
壓到非常高
所以呢如果是這樣的話
那投資朋友你就按照我們現成模式
我還是一樣4萬5千點之附近
你就把他吃苦降低到5成左右
因為有投資朋友就要問我這件事情
我會不會去調整我的看法
不會
因為各位投資朋友
現在是8月中
半個月前
你緊張的鑰匙
就叫你不要賣
也是我在叫你不要賣
現在叫你賣也是我叫你賣
奇怪 投資朋友
裡面你是住在一個國家
你半個月前跟半個月後
台灣還有全世界不都是一樣嗎
沒有變啊
變了是什麼
你原本變得很悲觀
你現在變得很樂觀
這位置我還是小心提醒投資朋友
就是在這邊
不要做一個追蹤動作
為什麼呢
各位去看一下
過去呢從今年以來
連長四天以上大概有六次
然後呢
我們過去發現
除了每一戰爭
開戰後的四月份
就從四月份五月份那段時間
曾經有連長之後
它可以連續往上攻來到4萬點以上這個位置
除了這次以外
你會發現從今年以來
連續漲4天以上的
最後面有一個情況
一定會拉回到月線
一定拉回月線
我們來看一下
像今年在2月份的時候
從圖上可以看到
連漲了4天之後
甚至更多天
粉紅色線叫月線
你會發現
後來都回到粉紅色線
就是月線位置
然後呢
5月份我這邊有特別框出來
也是一樣
你會發現連漲四天之後
後面都來碰到月線
5678都一樣都有情況
換句話說現在已經連漲了四天之後
那禮拜五
真的四天就踩擦車
然後就有點
在46500點這附近之前先踩擦車
我個人認為說如果真要買
那去目前的月線大概在43600點左右
換句話說
你賣4500
我們不認為你會吃虧
因為你只要相信一句話
這個大盤有高有低
高的時候你把市場賣掉
低的時候
你再把它做買進
相對這個資產才能夠持有保態
是
我投資本來可能會想說
難道你不積極的把他
不會買買滿嗎
會不會發現如果你在4萬點4萬一買進的話
你現在隨便買
哪一檔股票應該都賺錢
但是如果你在4萬5或4萬6以上買的
你現在買或許會賺錢
但是那個可能要手腳快
你就不會像4萬1
或是4萬點那時候買
那麼輕鬆之戰
你現在把所有K線圖調出來看
基本上你只要那個4萬1附近你買的時候
你會發現基本上隨便買
5% 10%
都一定會有
甚至20% 30%也會有
所以呢
如果你懂我所講的
你只要留有現金在
你隨時
等待這個機檔
機會在做進場就可以
那我們來看一下投信
過4萬4以上買超的部位變小
那當然禮拜五稍微有增加到70基因
但是也還有
也沒有變成非常多
我個人認為說量能不增
9日KT已經進入到超買區
我個人認為說
就是我剛才講吃骨到5成
如果來到4萬6
我不是就叫你不要賣
甚至要降低到剩下4成
那這部分來講就觀察4 6 3 5 0
這個4萬5000點的3%的上元的位置
我想這個部分
我還是秉持我先前的看法
長線的部分
因為這次的雙挨效應
你可以提升到4萬2
也就是說4萬點
你要再見很難再見到
那這邊位置來講的話
外資最近轉大幅的買超
但是空單沒有發現到
沒有明顯的下降
雖然禮拜五還有降
但是那個部分降格1000多口
其實坦白講
他現在目前的口味
口數還有將近有8萬多口
還是算是非常高
所以我個人比較偏向是短多的這種效應
那口性的高檔買超變小
我認為說現階段
你還是等到穩健區再做買進
除非這個量能一直在放大
外資持續願意大量做買進
那可能就會改變我們現錢的幹法
好 那等到回到4萬3文件去的時候
你再把它加碼到6成到8成
然後回到超級文件
你的持股比這種再提高到8到9成
我的看法還是一樣
不會因為今天大漲
或來到4萬5以上
我改變我的想法
同樣的之前
來到4萬1 4萬點的時候
我不會改變我的看法
我都一樣不會去改變
因為企業獲利數字就差不多
提醒大家一下
如果來到4萬6的話
就表示今年的漲幅就是差不多6成
6成不能說太多
但是如果能夠拉回一些的話
可能會舉會走得更穩健
另外一個部分也是到少數人不會去看的部分
今年的第二季尾巴之後
7月份會出現大跌
最主要是各位去看一下
第二季的成交量
計的成交量是74.45兆
比今年的第一季44.35兆
大幅增加快七成
從圖上你可以發現到
今年的第二季之前也就是說
今年的第一季跟去年的第四季
這樣的量你會發現很溫和的增加
但到了今年第二季的時候
成交量明顯很暴增
那暴增通常就是下一季
它走勢就會比較辛苦
換句話說這一次
很多人就會認為說48000點我馬上回來過
我跟各位講你不用想太多
不用想太多就是不會一次過
因為畢竟你要看那種成交量
這種情況就像在21年的時候
你發現21年的第二季
大概29兆
然後比第一季的19兆
大概增加56%
但你會發現
在先前的時候
也是量很溫和增加
大盤就可以實際上新高
換句話說
現在走勢
更認為會比較像
21年第一季之後
這種高檔在盤準部分
所以我認為說
以現階段
第二季如果到
8月中的收盤價來講
目前是呈現一個
算是修正不是很大
那我們上次也提到過
8月份的指數
不太可能會把 7 月份的
這個蝶幅完全刺下
所以我想
你要新要有一個定件
你不要看漲
你就看樂觀
看蝶悲觀
那你永遠就在做一個最高薩地的動作
我們再回頭來看一個另外一些角度
央行 7 月份在剪發定存單超過 740 億
換句話說
他也幫整個市場上的資金
也在注入到 1.46 兆
各位會發現
央行的定存單
未到期的定存單
在今年 1 2 3 4 月份的時候
相對是比較高
到567
來到相對比較低
你會發現好像跟股市走勢好像完全相反
這錢就是要流入到股市去
那我們來發現一件事情
就是上禮拜我有看到這則新聞
我想也跟投資人
還有甚至是我們也比較投資的年輕人
來分享就是你還能不理財嗎
各位發現你的薪水是越來越高
各位發現
你原先在109年的時候
大概4萬2
然後到目前將近快4萬9的薪水
好像每人越來越高
但是呢
你會發現
月薪的中位數也越來越高到3萬9
但是呢
低於平均的月薪的
者位的人數的比
卻從66%
創新剛剛來到7成
換句話說
將近有7成的人
領不到平均月薪
所以呢這個部分
我想當然最主要因為是高薪族
拉高了平均的月薪
另外來講就是產業移工
還有部分工時人數增加比較快
造成這種現象
但不論如何
我們可以發現到現象就是
你一定要做理財
否則從109年統計到現在
你要發現經過了將近五六年的時間
如果你沒有去改變你的想法
改變你的策略
你肯定永遠還是會在低於
平均月薪人數的部分
因為這個大概將近有600萬的人
受雇員工的人數是這樣子
而這次的這個部分
也反映到一種情況就是
電子零組件加班
還有電腦電子光學的製品
加班的時間都創下這47年的
同月的稅高
那當然人家領高薪也有原因
也加班
所以既然是如此的話
那我覺得你要去調整你的策略
當然不會叫你現在買
要馬上去在京橋買補票
如果能夠配合我的高低點進出的話
我相信應該會改善你的方式
我們再來看一下
這張圖6月21號
261集講到現在
是 再放一次
再放一次
因為我會每一次會把它更新
現在位置已經快接近了
46500點位置
然後已經快接近到超級積極區
所以我接近你
更要講低時骨比重
你有沒有發現你現在抽心態
做法是不是像越來越積極了
快要超級積極了
那上次呢
跌到399000多
4萬點的時候你有沒有發現那文件
然後到395000點的時候
我第一次用兩倍ETF正數的
然後那叫超級文件
你有沒有發現這張圖的文字
我全部都在一兩個月前都已經完好
所以你現在的心態有沒有變得很積極
肯定有很積極
而且如果下禮拜來到4萬6千
點以上
以後會更超級積極
什麼股票都是很強
什麼股票都可以買
等到又拉回的時候
什麼股票好像又不好
所以我還是建議來回座操作
因為畢竟第三季的行情不是這麼走的
其實這張表已經連續兩集都有放了
我有看到有一些朋友會很擔心
會不會一直往上就往上
事實上當然什麼事情都有可能性
但中大膽他的路線是很一致的
他希望能夠在穩健區跟積極區這一段來做
下面就要超級穩健
有時候不一定會跌得那麼深
上面超級積極
他也希望大家不要因為盲目的樂觀
導致受傷
既然想法是一致的
那認同這份理念的朋友
應該就可以體會到
為什麼4萬點可以大家買
4萬5000點以上
卓量的做一些解碼
不是教大家出廠喔
因為理財是非常重要的一件事情
剛剛講的
平均薪資往上走
可是平均薪資以下的人的占比卻變多了
希望大家從定存
或是從哪邊流到股票市場的錢
是能安穩賺錢的
如果認同這份理念
再來訂閱我們的VIP吧
我會把訂閱的連結放在留言的第一則
那我們就VIP先吧
字幕by索兰娅